depuis ce matin constitue l'essentiel de
l'actualité de ce vendredi l'importance
de l'enjeu
la fronde des élus locaux qui n'ont pas
suivi les consignes des états-majors de
l'opposition les conséquences de ces
élections qui risquent de redessiner la
droite républicaine et l'ensemble du jeu
politique français ou minutes donc de
cette édition de 50 minutes des duplex
en direct de la plupart des régions avec
aux côtés d'arlette chabot les
interventions des responsables
politiques comme françois bayrou
jack lang jean marie le pen réaction
également d'elisabeth guigou
toute la rédaction de france 2 réunit
pour mieux vous informer au terme du
scrutin de dimanche dernier voici
d'abord la nouvelle carte politique des
régions telles que se présentait en
début de semaine la gauche plurielle est
arrivé en tête dans 11 régions sur les
22 en métropole la droite l'emportant
dans sept autres régions tandis que
droite et gauche mais kaka égalité
parfaite dans trois régions aujourd'hui
et trois régions aquitaine limousin et
nord-pas-de-calais où la présidence
socialiste
huit autres ont à leur tête un président
de droite avec notament en auvergne
l'élection de valéry giscard d'estaing
d'adrien zeller l'alsace ou de gérard
longuet en lorraine et comme vous le
voyez sur la carte
cinq présidents de région de droite ont
été élu grâce aux voix du front national
un sixième qui a été élu dans les mêmes
conditions en franche comté a
démissionné enfin trois élections se
dérouleront lundi en ile-de-france
midi-pyrénées haute-normandie
elles ont été reportée faute de quorum
l'élection en région paca elle aussi été
reportée l'a dit nous y reviendrons
commençons avec la région rhône alpes où
la droite et la gauche sont à égalité
le million qui a été réélu grâce aux
voix du front national
cet après-midi-là été suspendu de l'unef
par françois léotard avec charles millon
c'est une personnalité nationale qui
accède à la présidence de la région avec
le soutien de l'extrême droite son
élection a été accueilli par des slogans
ni ans d'émission mignan que la boue par
les élus de gauche didier guyot thierry
simonet je demande
je demande aux élus du front national d'
apporter leurs suffrages à charles
millon le deuxième tour de scrutin
débute et les 35 et musique nationale
annonce tout vote jambes tonnerre à
gauche plurielle charles millon a
baptisé avec le diable aujourd'hui
l'élu de la droite négocier plusieurs
jours en catimini aucune dans les choses
et classent à droite et qui si l'otage
du front national ce fut léotard a parlé
de marionnettes fonction des
marionnettes invectives noms d'oiseaux
suspension de séance altercation dans
les couloirs le climat est lourd
il avait 93 suffrages charles millon et
lui n'a pas fait le plein de sous pour
trois de ses colistiers se sont abstenus
malaise dans les rangs
moi je ne m'estimais pas dans cette
démarche là donc je me suis abstenu et
je suis bien au sortant ump aujourd'hui
chaque année prend mais ça c'est le
genre d'histoire dont un champignon
l'argent a fait le principal intéressé
lui balaie d'un revers de manche toutes
les critiques qui fusent à son égard le
voici fussent pendus de l'udf jacques
chirac leur ai téléphoné
qu'importe il le crie haut et fort il
n'a pas signé d'accord avec le front
national et son programme ne changera
pas
charles millon doit maintenant procéder
à l'élection d'une quinzaine de
vice-président la gestion s'annonce en
tout cas délicate car la gauche tout
faire pour le harceler et certains de
ses colistiers ont d'ores et déjà
annoncé qu'il ne participerait pas à
l'exécuter et nous rejoignons en direct
de lyon didier guyot l'élection de
charles millon à un certain
retentissement en tant au plan national
qu'au plan local quelles sont les
réactions ce soir l'idée côté béatrice
érection sont bien sûr très nombreuses
j'en étais très contradictoires aussi
vous avez la gauche comme vous l'avez
entendu la gauche plurielle qui condamne
fermement cette ambiance de fête
beaucoup la redoutée en parlait comme un
accord dont j'ai déjà passé depuis
mercredi mais certains élus de gauche
sont également très étonnée par
l'attitude de charles millon on avait
connu dans le passé charmian très
combatif vis-à-vis du front national
d'ailleurs on se souvient pendant la
campagne et aral bruno gollnisch avait
dit que peut-être il était préférable de
soutenir jean jack queyranne plutôt que
chars minet mais les choses ont changé
ce soir d'autres réactions cette fois ci
des élus de droite il est ce bien sûr
qu'ils applaudissent cet accord qui sont
tout à fait d'accord il y a ce par
contre et qui redoute cet accord on l'a
vu cet après midi certains élus de
droite se sont abstenus quand les
radicaux continuent l'espère et puis il
ya également tous ces élus de droite qui
savent pas trop ce soir à quels saints
souvent ils ont failli charmant or si
déliter mais s'ils font partie de ce
tout c est lui qui aujourd'hui se
demande vraiment où se placer sur
l'échiquier politique
merci et didier en languedoc-roussillon
pas de surprises réelles mais c'est dès
le premier tour que jacques blanc a fait
le plein des voix de la droite et du
front national face au socialiste
georges frêche jacques blanc qui aurait
été félicités quelques minutes après la
réélection par allama de la nuit même
présidente de démocratie libérale
française david bernard grenoble jacques
blanc en piles pour la troisième fois il
est élu président de la région
languedoc-roussillon et déjà
affaires reprennent sauf airbus et la
pénitence et les résultats sont tombés
le président udf sortant recueille la
majorité absolue au premier tour du
scrutin rpr et l'udf était pourtant
minorité avant cette assemblée 22 élus
mais l'apport des voix détresse
concilier front national lui a garanti
son fauteuil
je n'ai je le répète signé aucune
alliance aucun accord et je n'ai fait au
plus de complaisance
puisque je n'ai fait que reprendre les
thèmes de ma campagne que j'ai mis en
forme dans ma déclaration de ce matin
qui est une déclaration publique que
chacun d'ailleurs pourra lire tout le
programme du front national studio dans
cette déclaration d'affirmer les élus
frontistes citant notamment la baisse
des impôts et la sécurité dès lors ils
n'ont même pas présenter de candidat
nous allons javier accéder à l'un de ces
pays qui vous allez voir que les choses
vont aller maintenant
très vite la gauche plurielle qui
détenait la majorité relative mais
vivement en cause la droite républicaine
ici nous avons vu les siens responsable
du rpr à languedoc roussillon voté avec
le front national
nous avons dit messieurs rester entre
nous à vichy nous restons en bas
respirer l'air de la france libre
quelques minutes après son élection
jacques blanc était suspendu de l'udf
mais en même temps il a félicité de la
part d'alain madelin
le président démocrate a l'une des
composantes de l'udf
un paradoxe c'est qu'on ya les
difficultés de la droite classique face
au front national
et puis philippe séguin président du rpr
s'est exprimé en fin d'après-midi ils
parlent d'une terrible condition je vous
propose de l'écouter en vérité une fois
plus on choisit de faire tenir leur
petit sou dans leur petit coin cela et
tous ceux qui auront la faiblesse de
issue en acceptant des postes leur
équipe se met trop en mouvement est
parti de nos positions
cela vaudra en particulier de sueur pour
les membres de mouvement même si pour
l'heure aucun ne se trouve dans
contravention avec la nuit qui avait été
défini cette terrible condition était
certainement inévitable étaient
probablement nécessaires
nous savons désormais sur quelle base
sera la reconstitution de l'opposition
républicaine
en respectant les engagements qu'elle
avait pris en faisant ce qu'elle avait
dit elle s'est donnée une nouvelle
crédibilité
elle a montré sa conception de l'action
publique
il fait passer des convictions en touche
ou supérieur
désormais quand elle affirmera ou
proposera quelque chose on pourrait la
croire et en particulier quand elle
défendra ses valeurs car il ya place
plus que jamais dans la politique
française
pour ceux et celles qui refusent la
division des français
le climat d'affrontement ben hypocrisie
l'absence de désintéressement ans ceux
et celles que rejette la violence d un
les responsabilités des autres pour ceux
et celles qui avec fierté trois nations
l'autorité de l'état dans la liberté
dans les vertus du travail pour l'esprit
des responsabilités dans la famille la
solidarité et l'égalité des choses quand
ça derrière ou un bonsoir je ne sais
plus tard ensemble ces déclarations fixé
gars qui parle de transition chérèque
apparemment il ya une véritable fronde
des élus locaux contre les appareils
politiques
ça veut dire que personne ne vous écoute
plus est-ce qu'il ya encore une droite
toujours des enfants
ils ont perçu aujourd'hui quelque chose
de très grave et c'est pas la peine de
me dire le contraire
il s'est passé quelque chose qui pose
une question naturellement à
l'opposition et à ses dirigeants mais
aussi je dirais à l'ensemble du jeu
politique et peut-être au-delà
je pense par exemple que les médias n'en
sont pas n'y sont pas extérieur la
question se pose à tous et cette
question elle va naturellement entraîné
une réponse qui sera une reconstruction
de l'opposition
sur des bases nouvelles dis moi je crois
cette réponse
enfin la question qui se pose c'est
d'une part en effet qu' un certain
nombre d'élus de l'opposition n'ont pas
saisi ou perçu la gravité des choix
qu'ils allaient faire ils ont cru que
c'était des choix locaux limiter à des
arrangements nos qu'on est en réalité
c'était beaucoup plus rare est beaucoup
plus profond c'était une transgression
de quelque chose à quoi beaucoup de
français à terre beaucoup plus que de
leurs idées politiques nées d'une partie
de leur âme
et là c'est vous ce qu'ils ont choisie
il voulait partir a dit on vous laisse
bien laissé sur les camry salut qu'au
deuxième jour
pourquoi ce choix s'est-il fait de cette
manière parce que je crois il faut avoir
le courage de le dire il y a eu une
poussée très forte de la base des
électeurs de ceux qui s'adressent aux
élus de ce qui leur parle ils ont enfin
tout tout de même le lagon ch et ultra
minoritaire et vous n'allez pas laisser
les régions à la gauche comme si comment
dirais-je il y avait un sentiment
d'exaspération à l'égard des leçons
constamment répété sur un ton raisonneur
et supérieur qui paraissent ne pas
prendre en compte la sensibilité et les
problèmes des gens
c'est au moins autant à l'égard de ce
système donneurs de leçons qu à les
garder
l'instruction que les états-majors
données ou que les responsables tenait
c'est au moins autant contre cela que la
révolte a eu et cette révolte elle
s'adresse à tout le monde
elle s'adresse par exemple monsieur
jospin qui a fait hier une intervention
à mon avis très mal à propos de
malvenues elle s'adresse à vous autant
qu'elles s'adressent à nous je ne veux
pas en commandite j'en ai lu des la
responsabilité nous avons notre part de
risques de responsabilité mais tout le
monde doit comprendre sa part peut-être
chez lang mots seulement un tamis pour
l'instant mais nous allons évidemment
vous retournez tout au long du séjour du
printemps ces trois mois beaux jours
c'est un jour triste est un très triste
et sombre pour la démocratie française
on peut comme on veut tourner autour du
pot
les choses sont là on démocratie il ya
une règle claire quand on prend un
engagement devant le peuple
on le respecte et l'engagement qui a été
pris par la droite républicaine dans la
gauche face aux électeurs pendant des
semaines et des semaines était qu' un
parti aurait la majorité relative qu'il
revendiquerait la présidence et là où
l'on ouvre la majorité relative
ils revendiquent la présidence ce que
nous avons bien l'application parce que
là nous étions minoritaires
nous avons fait la place à la droite
républicaine et sahel s'est pas produit
aujourd'hui est un grand nombre
d'électeurs y compris d'électeurs de
droite ont le sentiment d'avoir été
floués et trompés et le sentiment qu'on
leur a menti puisque impact été conclue
localement région par région avec les
élus d'un parti a pour le parent chollon
mais aux fascistes vous n'êtes rien de
réunir les six langues mais j'aurais
tout de suite que nous partions en
provence alpes côte d'azur
une élection aujourd'hui à
rebondissements depuis ce matin tu ne
sers particulièrement tendues avec
soudain l'hypothèse d'un candidat
surprise qui se présenterait si françois
léotard sous l'un tient finalement une
partie de l'udf et du rpr a demandé la
suspension de la séance jusqu'à lundi la
situation évolue d'heure en heure en fin
de journée on vient d'apprendre que
l'alliance était définitivement suspendu
jusqu'à lundi compte rendu roland sicard
et yannick aroussi soit demandé une
nouvelle suspension de séance
et cette fois ci joue devant monsieur le
président nous l'accorder jusqu'à lundi
je vous apporte satisfaction c'est l'un
des échanges les plus cours de la
journée mais certainement celui qui
provoque le plus de sens est le doyen
d'âge fm de l'assemblée accordent sans
l'ombre d'une hésitation une suspension
de séance de 48 heures au rpr christian
estros la gauche s'insurge françois
léotard n'en croit pas ses oreilles
le nouveau construire vargas nous avions
deux points des solutions pour les uns
premier tour et nous en trouverons une
pour le point des deux premiers à gauche
on se plonge dans le code des
collectivités locales pour reprendre la
séance au plus tôt pour le ps il n'y a
pas l'ombre d'un doute
la session doit continuer avec un
nouveau président udf 7
et nous dénonçons le caractère illégal
et encore une fois factieux d'une telle
initiative
le préfet des bouches du rhône est
appelé pour régler le problème
finalement la séance est bel et bien
suspendu jusqu'à lundi
michel vauzelle crie au scandale c'est
un coup de force président d'âge moyen
des cétacés dans l'illégalité
avec l'accord manifeste du front
national et de quelques élus de droite
lundi tout recommencera
les discussions de couloir les coups de
téléphone portable les candidatures
surprises
les stratégies se font et se testeront
autant que metex et nous rejoignant
maintenant direct de marseille
elisabeth guigou bonsoir amoureuse de
réaction à cette séance en provence
alpes côte d'azur qui a été ajourné
après de nombreuses péripéties
est-ce que ce soir vous craignez pour
michel vauzelle le candidat de la gauche
écoutez c'est la démocratie fonctionne
et en provence côte d'azur michel vous
êtes élu les deux premiers tours de
scrutin ont montré qu'ils avaient une
avance de douze mois et sur françois
léotard et sur monsieur le pen et ce qui
s'est passé cet après midi c'est un coup
de force du front national je viens de
voir monsieur le pen s'est insurgée il a
téléguidé quitte cette affaire et
qu'elle n'avait formellement par
monsieur estrosi mais c'est le président
doyen d'âge front national qu'il a
accordée sans même jeter un coup d'oeil
au reste des légumes
c'est à coup de force c'est dans
l'illégalité la plus totale et nous
retrouvons là la séance suspendue de
fait sans savoir quand elle reprendra le
président d'âge est parti en disant à
lundi sans fixer de
voilà c'est ça le front national c'est
le coup de force
c'est l'illégalité et bien jean marie le
pen ou l'interview gronde dans quelques
instants merci elizabeth guigou passant
en picard n'est là les tractations
discrètes entre la droite et le front
national ont porté leurs fruits puisque
l'udf charles baur à vos quand la menace
communiste a été réélu à la majorité
absolue avec le soutien du front
national au deuxième tour
reportage guilaine chenu projet note
charles baur vient d'être élu président
de la région picarde pas une voix du
front national ne lui a manqué la gauche
réclame déjà sa démission
retour sur une élection qui s'est joué
en une heure et demie la gauche à la
majorité relative
la région est promise au communiste
gérard lalot pourtant dès 15h dans ses
rangs
c'est l'inquiétude les inquiets de
l'attitude de la droite dans le reste de
la france
charles baur le candidat de la droite
par un autre scénario
il a déjà dirigé la région pendant 12
ans et après des accords avec le front
national dans la vie europe sérénité qui
n'est pas partagé par tous à droite
mal à l'aise bertrand labarre est le
seul à droite à elle son désaccord dans
l'urne un vote blanc et là surprise et
pour le deuxième tour le front national
présent pas candidat les reports pour
toutes les voies sur la droite
viens de comprendre le front national
réagit à sa manière à la présenter un
candidat
et puis il a fait voter en sous main
pour charles baur ce qui prouve qu'il
n'avait pas sont également mal me laisse
alors quelle défense en avant avec 6
continue pendant à droite on commente
cette élection bonjour tous a dit vettel
car ni d'avoir un résidence communiste
allié à une personne ne s'en vouloir
quitter les musiques
une demi-heure après son élection par le
beurre à prendre la suspension d'une drg
bon si vous perdez suspendu lui dis
jamais que c'est sur les valeurs de
l'idf jeu le programme de molière
je suis et je pense que je suis en vie
ce soir charles baur annonce qui ne leur
a pas de big résidence au front national
le rpr ne devrait pas non plus prendre
deux postes exécutifs régional
écoutons à présent la réaction de robert
hue déclaration solennelle au siège du
parti communiste pour le secrétaire
national le suffrage universel et fouler
aux pieds la tricherie des élus de
droite aura de graves conséquences c'est
ce qu'ils disent mécontents
ce qui vient de se passer est un déni de
démocratie le suffrage universel est
foulée aux pieds
le résultat de dimanche dernier était
passé dans plusieurs régions il a même
transformé en son contraire pour
employer le mot de philippe seguin lui
même il s'agit d'une tricherie
cette manipulation ne peut pas ne pas
avoir de graves conséquences pour la vie
et la stabilité politique de notre pays
en continuant d alliance avec le front
national
ces dirigeants de droite ont ouvert une
brèche dans le barrage l'extrême droite
menant à l'élection de la région centre
avec contre le socialiste michel sapin
la victoire d'un edf lui aussi élu grâce
aux voix du front national au troisième
tour de scrutin
cet homme de droite s'est présentée
après que le député d'indre-et-loire
renaud donnedieu de vabres et décidé de
ne pas être candidat compte tenu des
pressions pour sa part l'ancien ministre
socialiste qui jusqu'àlors se disait
confiant avec une majorité relative de
30 sièges par le ce soir de déshonneur
reportage mais quelle d'armand patrice
des mnu bernard harang udf vient d'être
élu président de la région centre avec
l'aide des voix du front national
immédiatement les insultes fusent et
marie france stirbois n'est pas dans
l'air
bernard harang fait partie des élus rpr
udf qui ont renforcé cette semaine front
national pour parvenir à cet accord
débordant ainsi la tête de liste renaud
donnedieu de vabres lui refusant
l'alliance n'a pas voulu être candidat
c'est un état d'esprit politique un
changement de cap politique important ce
n'est pas la ligne qui a rassemblé nos
familles politiques pour la préparation
des élections régionales
donc c'est un changement de cap très
important voilà je ne souscris pas ce
changement de cap c'est clair s'agit pas
pour moi d'une alliance étudions mais
d'accord inter sur des dossiers
d'aménagement du territoire le plan pour
faire battre le socialiste michel sapin
a parfaitement fonctionné au troisième
tour le fl abattu ses cartes en retirant
la candidature de marie france stirbois
chien à temps plein je le sais sans les
habitants de cette région qui sont des
balles car ils avaient voté
majoritairement à droite donc il fallait
que la région est à droite
la région centre a donc elle aussi fait
sauter le verrou de l'alliance droite fn
et pour michel sapin
il s'agit d' un vendredi noir pour la
république comme en d'autres périodes de
l'histoire de france
certains ont choisi fait minoritaire
d'être dans le camp de la démocratie
d'autres ont fait le choix de
l'ignominie
cet après midi bernard harang a été
suspendu par la direction de l'udf jeu
le pen bonsoir vous êtes en direct avec
nous de marseille nous reviendrons tout
à l'heure sur la situation paca mais
plus généralement ce soir lorsque vous
regardez ces élections avec l'apport des
voix du front national vous vous dites
c'est la stratégie du phocéen stratégie
bruno mégret qui a marché parce qu'il
n'y a pas de stratégie wenger front
national il n'y a qu'une seule stratégie
c'est celle qui est défini par le bureau
politique est celle qu'exprime ses
responsables est d'abord son président
est plutôt à la russie mais grève non
pourquoi survenue ne comprenons pas je
dis pourquoi ne pas devoir pris cette
stratégie vous ne migrent et puis coup
mais ce n'est pas la stratégie de bruno
mégret je sais que dans les médias on
veut absolument imposer cette idée mais
ça ne marche pas ceci c'est bon propre
opinion c'est votre problème ça fait pas
le nôtre alors néanmoins la question
demeure pourquoi ne pas avoir tenté
cette stratégie plutôt lors d'élections
précédentes et ce qui nous faisons ce
que nous croyons devoir fait au moment
nous le faisons est ce notre
responsabilité
il y avait un prêtre évident c'est que
la gauche était minoritaire dans
pratiquement toutes les régions ce qui
était une combine ce qui était une
tricherie c'est de s'être partagé région
au bénéfice de celui qui arrivait en
tête des minoritaires entre le rpr udf
et la gauche plurielle socialo
communiste or nous estimons nous que la
règle de la démocratie c'est la
recherche de la majorité
sow lui dans une assemblée et c'est
cette recherche éminemment démocratiques
et républicaines qui a aboutit
aujourd'hui à la victoire des
adversaires des socialo communistes
comme le souhaitait d'ailleurs les
électeurs français de ses mouvements
qu allez-vous demander dans les régions
où josé lui ont permis à des hommes de
l'udf d'être responsable à nouveau de la
région qu'elle ait vu demander une
région qui viennent à obtenir ce qui
nous était refusé jusqu'à présent à
savoir le respect de nos millions
d'électeurs qui sont des citoyens à part
entière et non des citoyens à 2000 par
qui ont droit eux aussi d'assumer des
responsabilités dans la conduite de
leurs affaires
ce n'est là que le web et respect de la
démocratie et de la république dos et
jean la honte à la bouche en permanence
les mots qui sont vides et de substances
quand il les applique dans la politique
courant c'est d'ailleurs ce soir dans
six une victoire
le front national je pense que c'est une
victoire pour le front national puisque
la stratégie qu'il a établie a obtenu
pratiquement dans toute la france
la défaite des socialo communiste qui
était l'objectif recherché par le
mouvement et en même temps à cuillé par
les millions de ces actes en répondent
par oui ou non est ce que vous vous
présenterez lundi pour un nouveau tour
3e tour pendant cette pause ezio est ce
qu'il y aura là aussi un hacker jorion
une question claire sur ce sujet car
j'ai assisté tout à l'heure dans votre
journal à la présentation d'après court
extrait d'un de ma bouche qui disait
exactement l'inversé de ce que j'avais
dit en effet j'ai dit que il y avait eu
une opération de style factieux et ce
n'était pas bien sûr la suspension de la
séance
c'était la tentative organisée à
l'initiative du garde des sceaux
actuelle au bénéfice d'un garde des
sceaux anciens tous les deux socialistes
pour essayer d'imposer une espèce de
chauve y est comme à la doom en 1917 et
siégé sans la présence du doyen d'âge
qui avait levé la séance
c'est cela qui était factieux c'est cela
qui était antidémocratique
je rappelle que le président de séance a
répondu à une demande faite par le
représentant du groupe rpr l'indépendant
la séance airplay rue des bouchers
léotard a été pas de cul qu'il s'est
résigné à cet effet et qui ne s'est
révoltée comprennent qu en séance
publique
quand ils devaient rendre compte à ses
alliés socialistes c'est là elle est
faite du pacte il avait conclu au cours
du déjeuner spécial faire avec madame
guigou et monsieur vaucelles je suis le
pet simplement oui ou non vous ces
candidats ou non lundi au troisième tour
est ce qu'il y aura aussi une alliance
avec quelqu'un d'autre que françois
lyotard nous aurons demain est un autre
jour
nous verrons bien ce que nous ferons la
vie merci merci monsieur le pen partout
en bourgogne la gauche en bourgogne est
arrivé en tête en bois dimanche dernier
mais finalement
l'ancien ministre et ancien président de
région jean pierre soisson qui a été
réélu au troisième tour de scrutin avec
le soutien du fonds national
il n'avait pas caché qu'il ne refuserait
aucune voix pour obtenir la présidence
comme d'ailleurs en 92 tueur et kurt est
chaque garnich une pièce a été jeté en
l'air ne sait pas de quel côté elle le
retrouvera à cet instant juste avant
l'ultime vote jean-pierre soisson telle
au furet dans une nasse il accuse un
retard de cette voie il enregistre les
défections dans son propre camp mais il
sait que le fn représente 9 bulletins
la pièce va retomber du bon côté grâce
au souffle du front national ces neuf
voix pour supporter intégralement sur
son nom à la bouche du résultat c'est
une bronca dans le pire pour la popote
et nous entendons faire du conseil
régional le pôle leurs coquettes et puis
tu y es polje freeman front national
je n'ai pas cette impression d'être
pieds mallié je ne me suis jamais mis
dans une telle situation
je suis plus fort dans la situation de
diriger des choses et le voir comment
autour de moi les autres s'ordonne le
patron de la banderole des 20 mai c'est
moi immédiatement la gauche quitte
l'hémicycle
le vote de dimanche dernier l'avait
pourtant placé en tête
eh bien nous n'aurons pas varié au cours
de cette campagne en campagne a été
digne je le répète notre comportement a
été dit monsieur si je devais dire
encore un mot j'ai l'honneur de voir
camille jean pierre soisson devra gérer
la région maintenant mais à chaque fois
qu'il sollicitera le vote des élus il
devra avoir recours aux voies du front
national situation différente en franche
comté où l'udf jean-françois parce qu'il
a été élu avec le soutien du front
national a démissionné en fin de matinée
une attitude qui prend en compte à titre
personnel les consignes des états-majors
de l'opposition anne 15 du rejet jean
louis normandin
il ne sera resté que trois heures à la
présidence du conseil régional
l'homme est un peu sonné le politique
vient de jouer une partie serrée jean
françois humbert l'avait promis en
campagne pas d'alliance avec le front
national
c'est pourtant grâce aux neuf élus du
front face à jean marc blaizot arrivé le
premier ce matin sur de sa stratégie que
la droite traditionnelle va remporter la
présidence 26 voix contre 17 à la gauche
plurielle mais jean françois humbert
donne très vite le ton à surprise
surprise et demie promet-il
suspension de séance et climat
électrique à droite le président va
faire son choix il le qualifiera de
geste personnel mon attitude se doit
d'être en parfaite harmonie avec mes
convictions démons propos antérieurs
il est exclu que je puisse avoir été
porté à la présidence de cette assemblée
dans de telles conditions d'émission
nouvelles élections en vue on parle
alors d'un possible front républicain
entre la droite traditionnelle et la
gauche plurielle permettant d'écarter le
front national deux heures de
négociations échec
jean françois humbert et quelques élus
ne revienne pas en séance l'élection est
ajournée ce personnel je continue aussi
à m'interroger sur ce qui va se produire
pense notamment que le rhdp est
régulière aurait très bien pu rester
parmi nous continuer la séance
une fois y ont été en mesure d'élire un
président une nouvelle assemblée devra
donc élire d'ici à trois semaines un
président au conseil régional jean
françois humbert se représentera pas de
campagne électorale qu'elle s'ajoute une
journée comme celle ci très très tôt
pencher ce soir il repartira en campagne
dès demain pour les cantonales jean
françois humbert et ce soir le seul
président élu à avoir refusé l'alliance
avec le front national puis en auvergne
valérie giscard d'estaing a été réélu
comme on s'y attendait et son troisième
mandat
adepte présidence à bordeaux alors
qu'alain juppé se déclare est opposé à
toute compromission avec le front
national jacques valade a été battu la
liste des chasseurs n'a favorisé ni le
camp de droite de caen de gauche c'est
finalement c'est le socialiste alain
rousset qui prendra la tête de la région
reportage éric perrin pas d'alliance
droite fn chasseurs l'aquitaine bascule
donc logiquement à gauche les
félicitations pour le socialiste alain
rousset et l'émotion visible pour le
président sortant le rpr jacques valade
il aura fallu trois tours pour que le
candidat de la gauche plurielle soit élu
avec une majorité relative
ici les consignes des états-majors
parisiens ont été respectées la droite a
refusé la main tendue par le front
national
l'attirance républicaine qui a été la
plus forte
ici en aquitaine
je suis très heureux je suis très
heureux de ça je suis très heureux de
cette attitude parce que c'était une
question d'honneur de conscience d'abord
mais aussi de mettre l'aquitaine en
mouvement et le rôle des chasseurs a été
important en maintenant leur candidature
aux trois tours et en refusant
clairement de s'associer avec le front
national
ils ont rendu de fait impossible une
alliance droite fn alliance que beaucoup
pensaient entre voir en ce début de
semaine lorsque l'on écouté le discours
de jacques valade à la fin je passe en
début de semaine les choses étaient un
petit peu moins peur vous savez on a
tenu de taux d'abstention
c'était ce matin à l'écouté ce sont les
chasseurs qui en maintenant leur
candidature au troisième tour de la
présidence ont permis à la gauche
plurielle de l'emporter proprement dijon
je veux dire aussi que les chasseurs ne
sont plus simplement des arbitres mais
qu'ils peuvent être avec lui
représentant en quelque sorte les
maîtres chanteurs et fonctionnement du
conseil régional démonstration dès cet
après midi avec la constitution de la
commission permanente premier casse-tête
pour le nouveau président qui se
retrouve déjà à discuter dans les
couloirs
le fn est prêt à jouer les troubles
fêtes et les chasseurs à négocier au
coup par coup
dans le nord le député maire socialiste
de dunkerque michel delebarre a été
comme l'on pouvait s'y attendre pas la
décision de marie christine blandin la
présente écologique de renoncer à un
nouveau mandat
michel delebarre a été élu à la
présidence reportage et petit inverse
jean-pierre hester c'est sa première
photo officielle de président de la
région nord pas de calais michel
delebarre n'est pas peu fier il
attendait cela depuis six ans non la
journée avait débuté dans la nervosité
une minute de silence à la mémoire de
maurice schumann l'ancien compagnon du
général de gaulle disparu il ya quelques
semaines était un élu du nord
tout le monde s'est levé sauf du tout
mais hier ce sera l'unique quoique une
partition que l'on dominait écrite à
l'avancé la gauche plurielle s'est
reconstitué après le verdict des urnes
dimanche dernier marie christine blandin
présidente verts sortants trequesser en
général à candidatures d'élevage
quant à la droite classique elle n'a pas
voulu jouer ici l'air que l'on a entendu
dans les régions dont un certain nombre
de journaux on s'attendait à ce que nous
puissions candidat jusqu'au bout pour
recueillir les voix du front national
je crois que leurs amis leur nez dans la
mouise comme on dit chez moi dans la
bouse de vache le fn représenté par carl
lang et marine le pen l'une des trois
filles du leader d'extrême droite et
donc pas été isolés at il eu des
hésitations kunis certains avaient des
tentations mais finalement pas de
candidat rpr udf a aucun espoir
lui-même a rendu
agence étatique la droite n'a pas joué
la recherche des voix du front national
de ce côté là elle s'est comportée en
droite républicaine est consciente des
risques d'évolution pour la démocratie
donc on droite responsable il
écologistes auront leur part du gâteau
deux vice présidences sont promises aux
amis de marie christine blandin très
exigeant c'est une majorité de gauche
mais une majorité relative et remuante
il s'installe à la paix du nord pas de
calais en ile de france vous savez
l'élection du président a été reportée à
lundi les élus rpr udf ne s'étant pas
présentés à la séance
edouard balladur obtient un délai
supplémentaire de réflexion pour savoir
s'il acceptera de se porter candidat par
la gauche qui dispose d'une majorité
relative dénonce le procédé comme une
manoeuvre est un déni de démocratie je
cite séance houleuse émaillé d'une série
d'incidents dont une panne d'électricité
monsieur jack lang une question sur
quand même la part de responsabilité de
la gauche dans ce que beaucoup appellent
déjà un vendredi noir est ce que le
front national n'a pas été aidée depuis
fort longtemps tu que certains le
croient par précisément la gauche
socialiste
cette question je gagnerai paul sous la
corée du temps et cette légende sur le
qui ne tient il repose sur garde à vous
et moi à l'instant puis reçu monsieur le
temps je vous répondrai à cette question
qui est une contre vérité absolue
propager de rédaction en rédaction
et aujourd'hui on nous annonce une
excuse je suis aujourd'hui il ya un
mauvais coup qui est porté à la
république et il frotte que les paroles
soient en harmonie avec les sacs
je crois que le président de franche
comté à donnent l'exemple
il démissionne il me semble que les
hauts dirigeants de la droite devrait de
mordre ou cinq présidents de droite qui
ont été élus avec les voix du front
national en oeuvre action avec
l'engagement pris devant le peuple
démissionne à leur tour et que l'on
procède à de nouvelles élections mais
aussi dire que
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui révèle
une situation qui est très grave dans
plusieurs régions et fait constater
moi-même dans la région centre certains
élus de droite sont devenus des frères
siamois de livia les frères siamois de
non droit néo fasciste
là il ya un vrai problème pour la droite
elle-même qui se trouve aujourd'hui en
lambeaux ou ambiante
le troisième point que je voulais dire
c'est que il ya eu heureusement
notamment dans la région je suis dans le
sens d'une ailleurs aussi en france
notamment cet homme de la franche-comté
des hommes d'honneur qui dans cette
circonstance ont réussi à se conduire
avec dignité ne sont pas allés à la
chine enfin je voudrais dire à monsieur
le pen à ceux qui nous écoutent que ces
nuits minoritaires 85% des français ne
veulent pas du front national est
aujourd'hui par des combines par des
combinaisons par les magouilles
voilà que monsieur le pen et le front
national qui vont de 15% a réussi à se
faire larbitre tapeta que vous avez mis
en place et d'ailleurs monsieur bayrou
que l'opposition en tout cas la majorité
de l'époque n'a pas non plus changé
vous avez donc tous les deux une part de
responsabilité dans ses combinés ce
passage sujet sur lequel il faut le
cessionnaire je suis convaincue pour
avoir en accord avec lionel jospin à
paris un texte sur la rénovation et
démocratie qu'il faut absolument dont
les régions et dans les départements
instituer un mode de scrutin qui
précisément permettent de dégager une
majorité et échapper définitivement à ce
type de combines sous la table et en
coulisse loisirs aussi enfin qu'il ya
une possibilité pour le peuple français
de dire son sentiment
7 dimanche prochain puisqu'il y à ne
l'oublions pas des élections dans les
départements il est très important que
les électeurs français doit été floué
par ces combines d'aujourd'hui puis ce
dimanche prochain dire non au front
national
non aux élus qu'ils ont trompé et fasse
barrage par conséquent à l'extrémisme je
crois que si dimanche comme je le pense
ce produit un sursaut républicain ce
sera pas en avant important vers cette
rénovation que le japon nous en soyons
épargnés
tout à l'heure vous évoquez vous même la
question qu'il ya entre la basse comme
l'ont dit les responsables politiques
comme vous mais disons aussi que chez
les responsables politiques et les
divergences
elle avait bien dit ce soir qui fouette
ni sourds ni mère ni aveugles face à
ceux qui ne comprennent pas pour récuser
le principe d'un accord avec le front
national
les divergences de fond sur si cette
déclaration d'autres signifier qu'on
approuve ce qui est arrivé vous le savez
bien je ne serai pas sur ce que je suis
en désaccord je ne peux pas approuver ce
qui est arrivé il ya ce soir un grand
nombre de deux français de droite et du
centre qui sentent bien qu un risque
considérable a été pris et il a été pris
contre leurs intérêts la gauche a joué
avec le front national comme avec une
grenade consolant c'est bon jeu elle a
fini par exploser
elle explose contre tous tout le monde
pas seulement contre les responsables de
la droite et du centre
elles exploseront contre la gauche elle
explose contre une certaine
comment dire solidarité de la société
française je pense qu'il est très
important de savoir et de sentir que il
y à une attente des français qui n'a pas
été prise en compte
je dis que c'est une attente populaire
je dis que c'est une attente de bon sens
qu'un certain nombre de politiques qui
ont été conduites de leçons qui ont été
données sur un ton sentencieux aux
français était en décalage complet avec
ce qu'il ressentait de la vie si on ne
retrouve pas cela si on laisse ce
accusés
je sais bien que c'est fini donc il faut
aller très vite mais je voudrais qu'on
retienne ça si on continue à laisser
s'aggraver s'accuser le fossé entre ceux
qui se ressentent comme le peuple et ce
qu'ils croient être des élites lointaine
à ce moment là nous aurons d'autres
accidents
le fils devait fixer à ceux qui ont
respecté leur parole à droite et au
centre
une mission prioritaire c'est
précisément celles là qu' on essaie de
retrouver les gens qui se sont sentis
floués pendant un certain temps des
messages qu'ils avaient envie perdre et
c'est qu'on les entende qu'on parle avec
eux et qu'on renoue le lien c'est ce
lien renouer qui sera à mon avis la
meilleure garantie de succès
pour ceux qui respecteront leurs valeurs
et leurs paroles si le ceva héros hameau
de politique toujours pour vous dire
qu'en midi-pyrénées l'élection se
déroulera lundi prochain à toulouse le
président sortant marc censi n'a fait
aucune déclaration mais il semblerait
qu'il n'y aura pas d'accord avec le
front national en le raid et le
président sortant gérard longuet qui a
été réélu une élection sans problème au
troisième tour de scrutin alors que le
porte parole du rpr françois fillon a
été élu au premier tour président de la
région des pays de loire et puis en
poitou charentes les jean pierre
apparaît qui a été réélu après le
retrait de la gauche 1 ou encore pour
vous donner les résultats au martinez
que c'est le leader indépendantiste
alfred marie-jeanne qui a été élu et
pour finir ce chapitre politique peut
être le mot de conclusion pour revenir à
l'étirement oui on vous dit
nick rien n'a réussi à enrayer les
accords entre le front national et à
droite
en dépit des appels multiples des
leaders de l'opposition bien sûr ce soir
encore françois bayrou était présent en
dépit même les mises en garde du
président de la république lui-même
finalement ces accords au mieux été
conclue dérapages graves à lui des airs
puisque la plupart des élus qui ont
passé ces accords sont connus des fl eur
pour le rpr a sans doute que tu est
retenu un peu mieux c est lui qu assure
grave entre les responsables de
l'opposition et puis les responsables
locaux d'où assure qu'il faudra essayer
de remettre en place et de combler dans
les jours qui viennent
au fond la ligne anti froid en place
depuis 1983 n'a résisté donc à rien pour
confond trois raisons d'abord parce que
cette ligne on triche on n'avait pas
semblé gêné les victoires de
l'opposition ces dernières années ni aux
élections législatives de 93 ni aux
présidentielles de 95 7 x 2 échecs
successifs aux législatives de l'année
dernière et à nouvel échec aux
régionales
à une semaine on semblait insupportable
et un certain nombre de responsables
locaux deuxième raison sans doute c'est
la très grande proximité qui au fil des
années s'est installée entre ces
responsables de l'opposition et les
leaders locaux du front national se
seraient rencontrés régulièrement et
puis il y a eu au fond la prend et le
changement de stratégie au su du front
national que nous évoquions en tout à
l'heure avec jean marie le pen cette
fois le front national est décidée avec
un programme réduit minimal de tendre la
main aux élus de l'opposition classique
et faire enfin entrer dans les têtes la
notion de droite plurielle et ça a
marché
et ça marche ce soir non et puis il
faudrait pas non plus sous-estimer
l'impact négatif que t'être de certains
rappels à l'ordre moral de leader du
parti socialiste qui ont été perçus
comme les provocations par des
responsables de l'udf et du rpr donc
pour la première fois ce soir depuis la
guerre toute la droite est unie réunis
reste à savoir effectivement comment
réagir à une partie de cet électorat la
droite classique at elle aussi se sentir
floués comme une partie de la gauche se
sont floues et privé de sa victoire ce
soir comment ces leaders de la droite
classique vont renouer avec leurs
responsables locaux et régionaux
je crois que ce soir tout le monde non
qu'on fait de perspectives une seule
chose est perceptible pour tout le monde
ce soir c'est un grand désarroi merci
est à la bourre merci à vous monsieur
blaireau merci monsieur jacques lang
lyon dire ce soir sur l'élection des
présidents de conseils régionaux
le reste des régions où le reste de
l'actualité avec le meurtre d'une
fillette dont le corps a été découvert
dans un centre scolaire de vacances en
savoie
c'est ce matin que la petite ludivine
originaire du pas de calais a été
retrouvé sans vie pascal doucet
ludivine avait 12 ans elles se faisaient
une joie d'aller à la montagne la neige
était au rendez vous et les enfants se
plaisait à la pierre au fait un centre
aéré de l'éducation nationale la
fillette a été retrouvée à 6h45 ce matin
dans les toilettes attenantes à sa
chambre son corps ne portait pas de
trace d'agression mais le parquet
d'albertville pense tout de même pour
l'hypothèse d'un meurtre
plusieurs autres jeunes filles se sont
plaintes on l'arrêté importuner ou même
victime d'attouchements faits commis par
le cuisinier du fant par un cuisinier du
centre excusez moi l'homme est un
toulousain de 28 ans employé depuis peu
au centre il a été interpellé vers 8h au
bord de la départementale en état de
légère ébriété
l'autopsié de ludivine n'aura lieu que
demain alors pour l'instant seuls les
témoignages des fillettes accuse le
cuisinier ludivine était originaire
d'hénin beaumont dans le pas de calais
elle devait rentrer aujourd'hui avec ses
camarades tout s'était bien passé 10 et
la fille prématurément à l'école elle
était en classe de perfectionnement et
tout le monde l'apprécié c'est une
petite fille très gentille réservé très
calme qui ne posait donc aucun problème
donc je viens d'avoir le saoût la
journée les responsables de l'école et
le maire de hénin beaumont ont porté
assistance aux parents de ludivine et
rassurer ceux des 15 autres enfants de
la classe de neige
il rentre avec leurs instituteurs et à
l'assistant éducatif ce soir ou demain
des psychologues et des médecins les
attendent
et puis nous venons d'apprendre que
nadège bréviaire cette femme de 42 ans
qui avait enlevé un bébé a été condamné
par la cour d'assises du nord de douai à
huit ans d'emprisonnement pour donc cet
enlèvement de bébé dans une maternité
après avoir simulé une grosse telle
qu'elle parlait de ce besoin d'aimer et
d'être aimé
fête de l'internet aujourd'hui et demain
dans toute la france dans des dizaines
de lieux vous pouvez vous initier
gratuitement à ce réseau mondial de
communication reportage a fait ses armes
avec le soft bastille l'image est
officiel mais inédite
le ministre de la culture qui déclarent
des informaticiens des ingénieurs des
techniciens et la reconnaissance par
l'état de l'importance de ces nouveaux
acteurs de la société de la formation
1998 indique matin catherine trautmann
doit être non un de l'internet grand
public
qu'on le veuille ou non ce réseau
mondial d'information va bouleverser
notre vie quotidienne des citoyens et de
consommateurs on est rentré dans une
nouvelle logique post industrielle avec
virtualité échange mondial et internet
fait partie
en fait de cet environnement
en quelque sorte avec des moyens de
communication nouveau et qui permettent
de rapprocher les gens à travers
l'espace si seulement quatre pour cent
des français utilisent internet à
domicile
l'immense majorité pense que c'est un
formidable moyen d'après aux savoirs
exemple voici ce que nous avons trouvé
en quelques minutes sur le site du
ministère de la culture la restauration
d'un tableau de philippe de champaigne
la dernière bébé de blake et mortimer
les 1800 photos des héros de la commune
de paris
les plus belles heures de france comme
ici celle de corbeil dans les stones ce
site est consulté chaque mois est
millions perdre votre image forte de
cette journée l'enthousiasmé des enfants
qui découvrent internet dans les salons
de l'assemblée nationale ouverte au
public
sur le moyen-âge et tout et on peut
avoir des choses alors un petit clic sur
une souris mais vous naviguerez sur le
web à des coûts de partir en week-end
offrez vous ce premier voyage dans le
cybermonde on appris aujourd'hui la mort
de catherine sauvage la chanteuse
symbole de la chanson rive gauche est
décédé à la suite d'un cancer à l'âge de
68 ans elle était l'une des principales
représentantes de la chanson à texte
celle de saint germain des prés
puis un petit mot de sport pour vous
dire que l'as monaco affrontera les
italiens de la juventus turin en demi
finale de la ligue des champions de
football
match aller le 1er avril à turin match
retour le 15 avril à monaco
c'est aujourd'hui le printemps la côte
d'azur et le pib fleurs depuis trois ans
pour fêter le printemps
le parc floral phoenix de nice exposé de
80 variétés de tulipes du parterre de
son une fleur valérie van damme
originaire d'asie mineure latulippe est
devenu l'emblème printanier du parc
phoenix 100000 bulbes ont été plantés en
novembre pour éclore en cette journée
d'équinoxe c'est superbe
vous avez ensuite ici est une peu cheap
fleur de lys de niche hors de l'iss sur
la côte d'azur les tulipes ont plutôt
été arrosés de soleil ici elles sont
plus précoce qu'en hollande où elle fut
riche en mets panache et fleur de lys
double lecture plomb d'attiser qu'une
femme ce qui signifie turban les fleurs
ont d'ailleurs un langage universel au
printemps l'époque de l'amour il fallait
en connaître le sens on à la cuisine
blanche qui smvol de la déclaration
d'amour on à la tulipe bana chez qui
elle est plutôt l'amour fou de l'amour
l'amour fou et la crau triste philippe
lejeune qui est plutôt l'amour sans
espoir
à côté du cully toute la faune et la
flore du parc respire le printemps et
pour fêter le changement de raison il
n'y a rien de meilleur que d'observer la
nature
je viens de metz et jésus de la réforme
je trouve ça magnifique magnifique ses
fleurs ses heures tibet cecily toronto
sun life et se ressourcer
recharger les batteries au soleil le
printemps inspirent les hommes qu est la
visite et le bonheur
on y revient à voir
c'est l'heure de la sieste
la côte d'azur change de saison en
douceur avec déjà une envie d'été
se termine cette édition je vous en
rappelle le principal titre consacré à
l'élection des présidents de région
voici la côte ouest avec notamment
nouvelle élection banale
wade front national l'a été
elles ont été reportées foot locker